Oh boy, are we in for a metaphorical
gunfight at the US Supreme Court as a
huge legal brief has just been filed on
behalf of Eva Marie Gardner in that huge
case about whether or not you have a
constitutional right under the Second
Amendment to bring your gun into states
through which you're traveling. That's
right. In a sense, nationwide concealed
carry. Major brief has been filed on
behalf of Miss Gardner with a large law
firm. Very important Second Amendment
law firm. The Supreme Court is going to
recognize this. Let's break this down.
What does it mean for our rights? What
are the odds of Cert being granted?
We'll talk about it when we come right
back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
Forbox and Diner, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney member of
the United States Supreme Court Bar and
I'm proud to say the top voice of the
Second Amendment in America. Thank you.
2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. And of
course, as you all know, this Friday,
I'll be the keynote speaker at the
annual Gun Owners of America activist
dinner out there in Arizona. So, if
you're going to be out there in Arizona
this weekend, you know, swing by the Gun
Owners of America event and say hello.
I'll be doing the big speech on Friday
night and wandering around on Saturday.
All right, folks. So, this is very
exciting news. A very powerful
persuasive brief has just been filed on
behalf of the Second Amendment by the
law firm of Cooper and Kirk. Cooper and
Kirk of course handles many, many, many
cases involving the Second Amendment. Uh
they're one of the top law firms in
America when it comes to defending our
right to keeping arms and other things.
And they have just entered an appearance
on behalf of the previously prosay
client or the prosay plaintiff, prosay
criminal defendant, whatever you want to
call it. uh Eva Marie Gardner who had
sought cert from the United States
Supreme Court having been arrested and
convicted for possessing a firearm
without a license in the state of
Maryland notwithstanding the fact she
had a carry license in Virginia and was
traveling through Maryland to visit her
mother in Pennsylvania. This is a
crazily great fact pattern. Hate to see
Miss Gardner arrested and convicted of a
crime, of course. But with that said, if
you support the right to keep and bear
arms, there are few better fact patterns
to argue you have a right to bring your
gun into states in which you do not
necessarily have a license, provided
that you have your own concealed
carrying license from your home state.
The crazy facts here are so favorable
that I'm sure it's going to get the
attention of the Supreme Court. In fact,
it already has because Miss Garner filed
this petition and some Supreme Court
justice, you don't know who, it's at
least one, asked and the Supreme Court
directed the state of Maryland to
essentially file a response to see what
they have to say. And what Maryland had
to say was not persuasive in the least.
Nevertheless, the law firm of Cooper and
Kirk has come along and filed a reply
brief in support of Miss Gardner arguing
that the Supreme Court should grant SID
in the Second Amendment case. And they
did a great job in making this argument.
Let's start off with the introduction to
their legal brief in this case of Eva
Marie Gardner versus the state of
Maryland dealing with her criminal
conviction for possessing a firearm, a
handgun in her car driving through the
state of Maryland from her home state of
Virginia where she had a CCW to the
state of Pennsylvania where she was
going to visit her mother. Let's check
out this introduction for this brief in
reply on behalf of Miss Gardner. The
history of this case reads like a howto
guide on the way to flout the right to
bear arms. And this Supreme Court Second
Amendment precedent as thoroughly as
possible. While petitioner, meaning Miss
Gardner, was traveling through Maryland
from her home in Virginia to visit her
mother in Pennsylvania, she was forced
off the road by what she believed was a
police type maneuver. When the other
driver got got out of his car and
approached Petitioner, that's Miss
Gardner, in a way she perceived to be
threatening, she was terrified and
responded by engaging in a common,
effective, and non-lethal self-defense
measure, simply displaying the firearm
that she was licensed by Virginia to
carry and that she had brought with her
on her journey for self-p protection. It
is difficult to imagine conduct that
falls more squarely within both the
Second Amendment's plain text and
America's tradition of legitimate armed
self-defense. Yet, Marilyn responded to
this incident by convicting Miss Gardner
not for behaving inappropriately in any
way during the encounter, but solely for
bringing her firearm with her for
protection as she traveled along
Maryland's interstate
highways. Well, that's very persuasive.
very good facts, terrible situation.
It's going to get the sympathy of the US
Supreme Court. In fact, it speaks really
to that 2016 Supreme Court case of
Kitano versus Massachusetts which dealt
with stun guns. You may recall there
Jaime Kitano had been threatened by an
ex-boyfriend and she used a stun gun
that was illegal in Massachusetts to
fend off the ex-boyfriend and did so
successfully. But the outcome of that
encounter was that uh police officers in
Massachusetts arrested Miss Kaitano. And
of course in 2016, the Supreme Court in
a per courier decision overturned that
conviction effectively. Not entirely
true, but essentially said to the state
supreme court of Massachusetts, um
please reconsider this and do it the
right way. Get your act together. And
wisely the Massachusetts Supreme Court
um agreed and threw the case out. Now,
here you have a very similar sympathetic
fact pattern involving Miss Gardner. But
it gets even better because Maryland's
argument is, "Hey, Miss Gardner needed
to get a concealed carry license from
Maryland." But that blows up entirely in
Maryland's face. And why is that? Why is
this that Miss Gardner was arrested and
convicted of possessing a firearm in
Maryland without a Maryland CCW
before the June 2022 Supreme Court
decision of Bruin?
And the reason why that's super
important is that the Supreme Court in
Bruin in 2022
said specifically that one of the
Mayissue jurisdictions
that was similar to the Mayiss issue
jurisdiction of New York that was
unconstitutional
was Maryland. Which means that even if
Mi Miss Gardner had applied for a
concealed carry permit prior to this
incident where she was forced off the
road and had to use a gun in
self-defense in Maryland,
she could not have gotten a concealed
carry permit from Maryland because
Maryland was using the mayisssue
unconstitutional mother may approach to
concealed carry license issuing and the
whole system was illegal and
unconstitutional as recognized by no
less than the US Supreme report in Bruin
itself that said that Maryland was one
of those states like New York that was
doing things illegally.
So, it would have been impossible for
Miss Garner to have gotten a concealed
carry permit in Maryland at the time
that all these facts occurred when she
was uh arrested and convicted because
Maryland was running an unconstitutional
carry concealed carry weapons licensing
regime. And that is a point that Miss
Garner's attorneys made right here,
right now. Check it out. Marilyn's
conviction of Miss Gardner for carrying
a firearm without first obtaining a
Maryland license goes beyond irony to
farce. Because even if she had sought to
obtain a Maryland license, she would
have been legally barred from obtaining
one under the state's then existing
regime. At that time, Maryland still
enforced a quote unquote mayiss issue
licensing regime under which individuals
like Miss Gardner with merely ordinary
self-defense needs were entirely
prevented from exercising their right to
keep arms in public. Maryland does not
dispute this regime was and under Brewan
always has been patently
unconstitutional. Yet, it convicted Miss
Gardner for carrying a firearm for
self-p protection on her journey through
Maryland without first obtaining a
Maryland license that was legally
unavailable to her. So, that's great
stuff. It's great argument. Now, the
question is, and we've covered this case
a little bit before, how is all this
going to play out? Well, to begin with,
as a matter of the Brun methodology, you
start with the plain text of the Second
Amendment. the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed. Because Miss Garner wanted to
was carrying a handgun in Maryland with
a license from Virginia, no different
than a driver's license.
She used she had the gun in her
possession. She was keeping it. She was
carrying it in public for self-defense.
Thus, she was bearing it. And she
actually displayed it to protect her
life, to make sure she did not become a
victim of a crime. So there is no better
example of conduct by Miss Gardner or
anyone in America that falls within the
plain text of the right to keep and bear
arms for self-defense. So it's squarely
within the plain text of the Second
Amendment. And you know what that means?
The conduct falling within the plain
text and the second amendment shifts the
burden to the government, in this case
the state of Maryland, to show there's
longstanding historical tradition of
firearms regulation consistent with what
Maryland is trying to enforce, i.e. a
law that says that you cannot travel on
the interstate in Maryland, even if you
have a gun license from out of state
through Maryland without a Maryland gun
license. even in in even though the
license regime that was in place at the
time that she was arrested and convicted
was unconstitutional
because it was a Mayissue permitting
regime that was identical to the same
mayisssue peritting regime that New York
got knocked out in the Bruin case.
So what does Maryland do here? So
Maryland sort of hems and haws, but the
truth is they're not going to be able to
win in an honest way. In other words, if
we are in Plato's cave talking to
Socrates and Plato about the truth of
the matter, the truth of human
experience and whatnot, the answer is
quite obvious that Maryland simply has
no historical analoges or no
long-standing historical precedence to
show that there's an American tradition
of firearms regulation going back to
America's founding in 1791 when the
Second Amendment was adopted that would
say that a state could restrict ict the
ability of outer stator to travel
through that state to another state
bearing arms, carrying arms upon their
person for the purposes of self-defense,
which is a fundamental constitutional
right found literally in the Bill of
Rights.
And of course, she couldn't have gotten
the license anyway because the Maryland
licensing regime would not have granted
her to granted her one at the time
because it was unconstitutional and they
weren't giving it to anyone. Nobody was
getting licenses. So, she wasn't going
to be able to get one. even if she
applied for one, she wasn't going to get
one.
Now, moreover, not only does this brief
make the argument that uh there's no
historical firearms regulation
restricting out of status from carrying
guns through your state,
if anything, it's just the opposite.
There's actually evidence in the record
that states often made exceptions and
loosened up any of their local gun rules
for the benefit of travelers going
through the state. Here's what this
brief has to say in support of what I
just said. Maryland identifies no
evidence of any historical tradition
restricting the right of outofstate
travelers to carry firearms for
self-defense while in transit. Not from
the founding and not even from the
reconstruction era. Nor did Maryland
appellet court below point to any such
historical evidence. The decision below
upholding petitioners, that's Miss
Garner's conviction for engaging in this
conduct. Despite the state's total
failure to justify utter Bruins text and
history framework is irreconcilable
with this court's president, meaning the
Supreme Court's president. In fact, far
from supporting a restriction on bearing
arms by interstate travelers, the
nation's historical tradition in fact
conclusively rejects any such
limitation. In the colonial period, at
least four colonies required travelers
to carry arms with them for their
safety. And from before the founding
through the end of the 19th century,
American jurisdictions
routinely exempted travelers from
firearm restrictions otherwise enforced
in recognition of the acute importance
of armed self-defense while on the road.
Very powerful evidence. In this case,
silence speaks volumes. The fact that
there is no historical uh analoges that
point in the direction of you can
restrict travelers ability to protect
themselves with firearms as they travel
through your state is fantastic evidence
in our favor. and a lack of evidence in
this case messes up Maryland because
Maryland as the government bears the
burden of proof to establish a
long-standing historical tradition of
fires regulation that's sufficiently
analogous to this regulation i.e. the
law that says if you're from Virginia
with a concealed carry license, you
cannot go through Maryland with your gun
without coming to Maryland and getting a
license there as well. And that's crazy
talk, right? And that is exactly the
point made in this brief that points out
that there's over 20 million concealed
carry holders right now. And they want
to be able to carry nationwide. And yet
they're prevented from doing so for
among other reasons, places like
California and New York and these and
Maryland, these interstate travel hubs,
if you will, are getting in the way of
it. Check it out. The second amendment
question presented here is urgent and
important. The second amendment question
presented in this case is highly
consequential. The constitutionality of
the insurmountable burden imposed by
several states on millions of Americans
right to carry a handgun for
self-defense outside the home. That's
what's at stake. Of course,
approximately 20 million Americans have
obtained carry licenses throughout the
nation. And many, if not most of them
engage in interstate travel. Yet many
states like Maryland demand that
outofstate travelers go through the
ownerous process of obtaining in-state
licenses if they wish to carry firearms
with them for self-p protection when
traveling through the state. And that
includes states like New York and
Illinois which contain some of the
principal passageways of interstate
travel in modern America. Given the
inherent hazards of interstate transit,
the burden on the Second Amendment right
to armed self-defense is immense. think
that's a very compelling argument. And
by the way, remember how I've explained
to you on this channel that one of the
reasons you tune into the four box of
diner is you have to learn about other
areas of the law. You have to learn
about other areas of the constitution,
not just second amendment stuff. Because
if you don't understand the big picture,
you cannot be the best possible advocate
the second amendment right to keep and
bear arms. And this illustrates the
point because here is an example that
Miss Garner's attorneys are literally
arguing other parts of the Constitution,
pointing out that the structure of the
Constitution points in the direction of
ruling for Miss Garner, including the
full faith and credit clause, which
illustrates my point I keep driving home
on this channel. You have to understand
all aspects of constitutional law and
American law to be the best possible
advocate for the right to bear arms.
Check it out. The question presented
here also implicates fundamental
questions concerning the basic
federalist structure of our
constitutional order. The constitution
was meant to form a more perfect union
out of the conviction that a firm union
will be of the utmost moment to the
peace and liberty of the states.
The document mainly the constitution
furthers this goal in numerous ways
including by requiring each state to
give full faith and credit to another's
public acts and by guaranteeing by
guaranteeing the right of a citizen of
one state to pass through any other
state for the purpose of trade,
agriculture, professional pursuits or
otherwise. So there you have it, an
appeal to the structural constitution,
the full faith and credit clause, and
the understand that a union requires the
ability of American citizens to be able
to travel interstate across this great
country. And you do not check your
fundamental constitutional rights at the
border of any one state. And that is the
point that Miss Gardner and her
attorneys are making in this brief,
seeking from the US Supreme Court. And I
think there's a real chance that the
court might grant cert here. And if they
do, it will be a huge step toward
ultimately a constitutional finding that
we have a concealed carrying right
nationwide, which of course is the right
answer. We just need to get there step
by step. And I think if the court grants
in this gardener case, that will be a
very big leap forward in toward that
ultimate goal of nationwide concealed
carry and the right to do so. So fingers
crossed and candles lit. Okay, there you
have it, folks. Hope you enjoyed today's
episode. Make sure you follow me over
there on X4box of Diner. We're almost at
30,000 followers over there, so help us
get over that hump. And thank you again
for subscribing. If you haven't done so,
subscribe to YouTube and Rumble. And I
appreciate all your time. And we'll see
you again here soon at the fourboxes.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.